everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're continuing our
coverage of the second tournament in the
2019 grand prix being held in latvia we
are in round 3 and that means that we
have four competitors left this is a
heads up tournament you play the best of
two series against one person you get to
play white and black if there is a draw
after that you do go to tie breakers if
someone has one or is up half a point
after those two games they do move on so
we have four players left trying to get
to the finals based on where you end up
in the tournament you do get points
you're gonna play three of the four
Grand Prix tournaments all year and then
the top two finishers will go on to the
candidates tournament two of our
remaining four competitors we're gonna
be watching today white is gonna be
played by Alexander get it shook and
black is gonna be played by mvl quite a
few games we've covered so far from MVL
he has been dominating so far but now
exhiliration shook he is one of the best
players in the world and he'll be
looking to advance to the finals he
starts out with d4 Knight f6 pawn c4
pawn g6 and then the most interesting
third move I've seen in quite some time
and that is pawn to h4 seemed like we're
going down the Kings Indian approach was
not expecting h4 it off you want to try
h3 that makes sense you know usually
you're gonna see g3 castle on the
kingside fee and keto here to g2 and
then control the center of the board
over here bring Knight to c3 just your
common moves h4 is not common at all but
we do see c5 say I'm not gonna worry
right now what you're doing here on the
kingside the board I'm gonna go ahead
and attack the center specifically on
the queenside pawn d5 and then be fine
now this is similar to the bingo game at
where you give up some material here
you're really trying to get your
opponent to extend on the Queen side of
the board knowing that once they take
here that's exactly what Grichuk does is
it's very difficult for them to hold on
to this material you have a lot of ways
to attack the
since a while yes they are up a pawn in
material you know that you can get that
later on and this also frees up some of
the defenders that White has in the
center trying to control these central
pawns here so that's what MBL's looking
to do he continues with a 6 we see III
here opening up for the LightSquared
Bishop Bishop d7 fianchetto get ready to
castle on the King side of the board
Knight to c3 normal development move
Castle a knight f3 and then d6 just
solidifying the pawn chain a little bit
opens up for the lighter Bishop if you
wants to come down here generally gonna
end up on g4 can always come to b7 if he
wants to add another attacker on this d5
central square so it does have some
options as far as how he wants to
continue now that he has his pawn chain
on appear to a 4 and then the Bishop
comes down to g4 White has a few options
as far as how he wants to continue one
would be just your normal Bishop e2 I
think a lot of players would do this
especially after the bishop comes down
here the Knights being pinned down you
want to cast on the King side definitely
a safe play you also may want to start
attacking on the Queen side since your
opponent seems to be eyeing down this
King side start to push this pawn right
here pawn b3 this makes a lot of sense
just gearing up with your pawns here but
this starts to open up this line for
this dark squared Bishop there's no
longer any pawns here so depending on
how both sides continue here maybe pawn
recaptures Knight recaptures which is
definitely the pawn or the piece that
you would want to recapture with Knight
a6 Bishop c4 getting that so you can
cast on the King side centralizing that
Bishop Knight d5 and then after the
knight takes on d5 you can see this has
opened up for the bishop to take here on
a1 so because of that after the exchange
black would have a very good game here
we do have Alexander he looked at and
said yeah I don't want to have to think
about that later on I'm gonna play rook
to a3 yes this brings it up so he can
get involved into the game but really
just doesn't want to have to worry about
it he can now move these pieces
freely pond takes on b5 Bishop take so
always when you can capture material and
open up for something else in this case
castling on the kingside definitely the
way you want to approach it Knight a6 if
you want to go and exchange that's fine
this is going to be a good board for the
bishop pair something negative ships not
looking to do right away pani for just
centralizing the pawn chain here in the
center of the board night before and
this is a great outpost stops a lot of
the squares that white would eventually
want to go to Bishop down here e to
because this stops a lot of squares that
the Queen can go to as soon as that
Queen moves then I can come down here to
see to check and this is working the
rook right here on a3 so the bishop
comes back once to stop some of the
squares that the knight can go to Knight
d7 so starts to maneuvering a little bit
once to bring it down to e5 at some
point you also may want to go ahead and
take this night so that you can have the
the knight combo in the center of the
board castle on the King side Queen b6
rook e1 just centralizing Queen b7 here
just moving around a little bit Bishop
g5 this is now attacking this pawn on e7
and then the bishop takes as we talked
about and then after the exchange and
only after the exchange does the knight
come down to e5 doesn't want to do
before because he doesn't want the night
that was here on f3 to take it but now
this does a couple things one it really
sets up for some strong attacks the
knight can come down here to d3 and it
has protection from the other night we
can also have this Knight come down to
d3 does have some options it's
threatening this pawn on f3 and also
opens up the door for a discovered
defense with the Queen on b7 that's why
the Queen was brought back here so that
this Bishop on g5 cannot freely take his
pawn on e7 so a lot going on but MBL
doing a very good job of moving his
pieces around some great little outpost
from his knights and says yeah if you're
gonna have a bishop here that's fine
I'm gonna have my Knights work extremely
well together now that there's a lot of
pawns in the center of the board really
clogging up where the bishops can go to
aiexander continues with rook F 1 and
now poncey 4 starting to push on the
Queen side of the board pond b3 rook c8
just centralizing getting it more
involved into the game wasn't doing too
much here on f8 bishop comes down d2
recognizes there's a lot going on here
and then Knight d3 we already talked
about this because there's so much going
on here now how does white really
continue has a few options could take
with his bishop from here probably gonna
see the knight recapture still a great
outpost
maybe Queen e2 Queen d7 this is just a
really good spot from blacks perspective
he's just all up in the business for
white now could come back maybe the
bishop doesn't take he could decide to
go more of the route of the pond taking
here on c4 that's fine
Knight takes on c4 attacking the rook
right here so rook b3 attacking the
Queen could take the Queen Queen
recaptures that's fine and this move
right here Knight to d2 is when it would
be setting up forking the the rook and
the Queen here attacking both and then
after the exchange right here black
would end up after all of this in a very
good position and so this may be another
thing that white wants to avoid he opts
for the last option if we come back and
that is to play pawn f4 this does attack
the one piece right here that's
defending this Knight so that's many
times what you're gonna be doing you see
your opponent's they have a strong
attack and you say what's holding this
all together right now is this outpost
here on e5 so it pushes up with that for
trying to attack Queen down b4 just
trying to get all of his pieces involved
into the game and there's two options
that white has one is to bring his
Knight down here because this Queen is
attacking the rook the other one is to
play Knight to b5 this is an outpost
here it's also defending the rook I
always err on the side of getting your
pieces in much more aggressive positions
chess many times is in
game if you can be on offense
and just have very active pieces it's
always difficult for your opponent to be
able to defend against all of the things
that you have going on at night here on
b5 is much more aggressive than bringing
the night back to be one but then the
game we did seek addition to side to
bring his night down to beat one it is
defending the rook but it really is just
playing defense pawn pushes forward on
c3 pawn takes here so we did have the
knight eventually decides to take that
now the Knights gonna come to be to
knowing that he can take this Bishop
besides first to go ahead and tack the
Queen right here Queen c2 now the pawn
captures that Bishop on d2 Queen takes
the knight here Queen comes over and
takes on e4 so a strong attack coming
here this has also opened up for the
rook to start to swing down and it can
also be defended by the Queen on e4 so
you start to get a since MBL has been
building and building and building and
eventually he's going to break through
and start to attack his opponent
especially since the king said the board
is completely open right now
why continues with Queen taking on d 2
and then rooks e2 is we talked about
attacking the Queen Queen d3 just says I
need to start exchanging some material
here rook takes on e to decide to go and
take the Queen off which is probably
good you don't want your opponent's
Queen just freely attacking your King
after the rook takes then it comes down
to who can play the best in game now
white does have more material at this
point but it's also very difficult to
hold on to all of this and now that
there's pawns on both sides of the board
it's gonna be much better for black
because he can control much more of the
game night to d2 attacking the rook rook
g4 check King comes over here at h1
takes the pawn on h4 check King here - G
- and then rook d4 so both sides now
equal in materials we talked about but
you can see black has a much more
aggressive game after Knight f3
attacking the rook this is an
interesting move to me
a lot of people if they were viewing
this they would immediately take on d5
and this looks like a very strong move
you now have a passed pawn in the center
of the board you can easily swing your
rook here on d8 it's gonna be very
difficult for your opponent to worry
about that and then you can start to
swing over on the Queen side of the
board
but NBL is looking at this spot and he
knows that the only way he can probably
lose this game is if he lets these pawns
start pushing here on the Queen side of
the board so instead of taking this
material he brings his rook over here to
g4 attacking the king check King h3 and
then he brings his rook to b4 so this is
kind of higher level thinking that these
grandmasters going down where they're
calculating many many many moves later
on into the endgame and saying that yes
while it may look clear that I have an
advantage if I take this I do think that
there was some risk by letting the pawn
push forward here on before so I'm not
even gonna worry about this pawn I can
get that later I'm gonna stop this right
away on the Queen side so very high
level play from MBL here rook to b1 you
can see why it's definitely playing a
defense rook c8 getting aggressive in
the game King down here G 2 and then
rook c3 so getting up all on Wyatt's
business right here attacking the knight
Knight g1 playing full defense mode rook
c2 always want to get your rooks on your
opponent's second rank if you are black
that's exactly what NBL is done here
Knight to f3 just centralizing but it's
not doing too much rook g4 check King
down here to f1 rook to f4 attacking the
night's king comes to g2 attacking we do
have a two-fold repetition here
eventually we see the one move that's
different and that is the pawn coming to
g5 now rook to f1 gonna be a mistake if
the knight takes here on g5 a lot of
ways that this can go bad here but
essentially after the rook takes right
here this is going to lead to checkmate
so you don't even have to do something
where yeah you play your rope over here
to take the knight back that would work
as well but black actually hats
a checkmate that he can go down there's
a series of how this could end up but
one of the more likely scenarios and
this is a force made as well this is not
something that if they play a wrong move
here it would in it would definitely in
a checkmate so with that definitely
going to be better not to take this pawn
up here but just baiting your opponent's
rook to f1 trying to defend as much as
possible
rook g4 check King down here h1 rook c3
rook over here g1 rook f4 Knight down h2
and then we see rook takes on f2 and
then the end of the game is near cuz
after rook to c2 we do have Alexander
gonna ship with the white pieces
resigning and the reason for that is a
lot of variations that could come from
this but there's just no way to hold on
if you were to move his rook over here
to defend this Knight well that's just
going to be checkmate the knight can
yeah sure come here but that is going to
to fall if you try something else maybe
move the Knights because that would fall
Knight to f3 but then you could just
take the knight this is pretty logical
now you have a extra bishop here it's
gonna be very easy to have an in-game
win for black here there's just no real
good way to stop this if maybe you
brought your King to g1 well then the
rooks just gonna take on h2 similar as
we talked about before no way to stop
this so congratulations to in DL he will
be moving on to the finals we will have
a couple day break until we come back in
the finals but congratulations to NBL
and every time we watch this guy play in
this tournament he has done extremely
well even in this one playing the black
pieces could easily go down try for a
draw come back tomorrow and it's high
breakers which I think he would do
extremely well and he said not so fast I
think I can get a win with the black
pieces in he did so he's guaranteed at
least 2nd place but we'll definitely be
following
in the finals thank you guys so much for
watching thank you for following along
in the tournament's been exciting one so
far a lot of different openings and
lines we typically don't see so it's fun
to see that at the highest level play
but thanks again I'll see you guys in
the next video